[Music]
up until today deadpool has been one of
the most popular anti-heroes the marvel
universe has to offer the scarred
mercenary's last appearance was four
years ago and it has also been some time
since the infamous takeover of fox by
the disney company the big topic among
fans however is not so much the still
unknown release date but rather the much
desired rating many fans are wary of
whether the family-friendly marvel
universe will make an exception for this
film in a conversation with den of geek
screenwriters rhett reese and paul
roernick now spoke out about the
possible age rating accordingly we
should not worry about it as the two
have received great support for the
vision nevertheless between the lines of
the conversation resonates that disney
has not approved everything that the two
authors presented thus one or the other
crude joke will probably be left out
quite a pity considering the great
success the two authors had with the two
previous movies without anyone
interfering with them so an r rating
will likely be given as promised by
marvel boss kevin feige in the past
however with small sacrifices on behalf
of disney and the mcu whether the
project fails or can replicate the
success of its predecessors remains to
be seen a release date has not been
revealed yet
with box office takings of over 1
billion us dollars joker is not only the
most profitable r-rated movie but also
among the top three most successful dc
movies ever no surprise then that
immediately thereafter people started
demanding a sequel to the movie which
was originally intended to be a
standalone hit now director todd
phillips unexpectedly shared a new
picture on instagram which shows the
script for the sequel written by him and
his co-writer scott silver also visible
is the first title and it reveals more
than you might first expect foliadu is a
french term meaning madness of two this
describes a mental disorder in which a
delusional individual deduces his
symptoms on a close initially healthy
person as soon as the two people part
ways one person's mental disorder often
disappears many see this as an
indication that harley quinn will play a
decisive role in the upcoming joker
sequel however an appearance by mugger
robie in her starring role is considered
unlikely since joker is set in a
different universe than the suicide
squad films or harley's solo film birds
of prey as deadline reports the deal
with lead actor joking phoenix is as
good as sealed but after his convincing
performance in the first part anything
else would have been a disaster anyways
there's no release date yet but we will
certainly have to wait at least two more
years until the movie is released
a couple of days ago disney published
the first details about the upcoming i
am groot animated series as the name
suggests this is a spin-off of the
guardians of the galaxy series but with
baby groot at the center the former is
very different from comparable disney
plus series instead of a long coherent
story we will get to see a series of
so-called original shorts in other words
very short stories of course there will
also be the mandatory clash with other
mcu characters however it is not known
yet which ones these could be we do know
at least that vin diesel will be dubbing
groot just as he did in the guardians of
the galaxy movies so far our first
poster has been revealed showing the
little tree in a laid-back atmosphere on
a beach towel at the same time the
planned release date of august 10th 2022
is shown as well we are certainly
excited to see how the rather unusual
series format will perform
just recently the suicide squad actress
daniela melchior joined the cast of
guardians of the galaxy vol 3. shortly
afterwards deadline reported that
another actress had joined the cast the
targets of borat actress maria
bakalova's james gunn also officially
confirmed on twitter last monday it is
suspected that bakalova will play an
important part in the upcoming mcu
blockbuster gunn himself too spoke of a
particular person who would be given a
special role long before the
announcement
besides the borah subsequent movie film
the 26 year old was last featured in the
horror comedy body's body's bodies and
the bubble in addition to bakalova we
can of course look forward to a reunion
with bradley cooper chris pratt dave
bautista karen gillian palm clementine
vim diesel and zoey zaldana likewise
joining the cast are sylvester stallone
as taka agort as well as will poulter in
his new role as the immortal adam
warlock the guardian's next appearance
will be the upcoming 4 love and thunder
starting this july 8 2022 guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 will then hit theaters
on may 5th
2023 this september the most expensive
series of all time the lord of the rings
the rings of power will be released on
amazon in addition to four new covers
from empire magazine there are also two
more new images the covers show for
instance a battle ready galadriel the
two kaza doom rulers of during the
fourth and diesel and also the three
heart foot's poppy nori and sadak on a
fourth cover preserved exclusively for
subscribers we see an artistic drawing
of a snow troll two more pictures also
published by empire magazine show
galadriel again played by morphet clark
here she carries a torch and appears
noticeably younger than in the movie
trilogy says thousands of years later
the second image shows the alvin smith
celebrimbor played by charles edwards
who already appeared in the two video
games shadow of war and shadow of mordor
indeed he is the blacksmith of the
notorious rings and thus takes on a
crucial role in this story of the lord
of the rings further there was new
information provided by the showrunners
jd payne and patrick mckay in talk with
empire they revealed that the entire
50-hour series has already been thought
out and that there are many story lines
that will only make sense at the end of
the fifth season fans meanwhile are
still on the fence and there has been
some backlash against the first trailer
we will find out more details starting
with the official series premiere on
september 2nd 2022 on amazon prime
netflix geek week kicked off with
netflix announcing all sorts of new
movies and series some trailers were
also included and the following we would
like to present the highlights that the
streaming giant revealed one of the
undisputed hits was the cyberpunk
edgerunner series which is based on the
video game released in 2020 along with
the first teaser and a clip of the
animated series that was also a first
anime style poster to look at the
project is a collaboration between cd
projekt red and studio trigger and will
be available on netflix starting in
september 2022. another image was
published for the skull island animated
series which is a collaboration between
legendary and powerhouse although not
much information was given there was an
impressive pick of kong's gigantic
handprint the new one-piece series and
live action format will also be of
interest to many here too there was a
first video clip that presents the
detailed sets of the upcoming series you
can see for example the largest barratti
which has a bar hidden in the mouth of
the fish head however fans are still
doubtful whether and how the live action
adaption will be able to capture the
spirit of the one piece series a release
date has sadly not been announced as of
yet the new resident evil series was
definitely able to convince some fans
after the reboot welcome to racoon city
was rather moderately successful in the
new series we get to learn about two
time frames once before and once after
the outbreak of the infamous t-virus the
focus is on jake wesker played by ala
balinska who is the daughter of the
villain albert wesker in terms of
content the series will follow its very
own path and will only be loosely based
on the original game regardless we are
looking forward to it this series will
be released on netflix on july 14th 2022
to include our selection we would like
to introduce you to a new movie with a
great cast the gray man which has now
been known for quite a while is directed
by the russo brothers in the leading
roles we can see superstars like chris
evans ryan gosling and anna armas the
plot revolves around cig and cork gentry
who goes from being the hunter to being
the hunted and can only seem to rely on
the charming agent danny miranda the
film is scheduled for release this
summer on july 22nd 2022
apart from all the netflix releases we
have a lot of new trailers for you on
our channel this week among them is the
final trailer for minions 2 black adam
and prey in addition mcu fans should not
miss our new original on black panther
wakanda forever
[Music]